- [Aneel] Hello, everyone.
Welcome. Thank you for joining us today.
I'm assuming this is your first
reinvent session for 2025.
Woo. Alright, thanks for
giving us that privilege.
So today we are going to talk
about bridging structured
and unstructured data using AI agents.
Let me begin by asking you a question.
How many of you here
are building AI agents
or maybe they're running
AI agents in production,
or you're experimenting with it?
How many of you? Wow,
quite a few of them, right?
Anybody want to tell me what
kind of data you're using
for these AI agents?
Is it going against unstructured
data like files in S3?
Okay. Alright.
Is there any data that is
in relational data sources,
like structured data?
Okay, yeah, a few of you. Yeah.
So usually in enterprises,
a lot of knowledge
that we have of all these
enterprise systems from last 15,
20 years is the data is logged
in relational databases.
That's the predominant
data storage mechanism
in enterprises, large enterprises.
And we also have a lot
of unstructured data
over the past 10, 15 years
because we have so much of
data that's being generated
in all forms and shapes.
So this talk is about how do
you use AI agents to bridge
that data that is in different
silos in structured data
and unstructured data.
You use AI agents to
bridge all of that together
and have a intelligent system
that can go across these data silos.
This is a core talk.
So we will be doing,
demonstrating a building an
application here, application.
You don't need laptops.
If you try to follow us, follow along
when we are doing, it's probably
not enough time for us
to type all the codes.
So we'll be using some snippets vs.
core snippets to bring in blocks of code,
but you'll generally get
the idea how to build
this type of application.
My name is Aneel Murari, I'm
a senior solutions architect
with AWS.
I work with our nonprofit
financial industry customers.
I've been with AWS for five years.
I'm joined today by my
amazing colleague, Rafia.
- Thank you. Hello, everyone.
My name is Rafia Tapia
and I'm a senior solutions architect,
also working with non-profit customers.
I've been with AWS for a
little more than six years now
and really excited to share
some of the code we've created
for this code talk.
So we can start.
- [Aneel] Alright. Yeah.
- [Rafia] Alright.
So the first thing we'll do is we'll kind
of briefly talk about the
architecture of the application,
the code, which we will be building today.
On the far, let's see,
your left hand side,
you'll see there's a
UI application, right?
We've written that in
streamlit, nothing complicated,
but that UI will be able
to take a user question
and then be able to answer
that user question via two type of data.
One is the unstructured data,
which we have shown on the top yellow pane
on the architecture diagram,
in the unstructured data
would be coming from
Bedrock knowledge bases.
We have one slide
where I will be talking a
little bit more about bedrock
knowledge bases.
And then the structured data,
which we will be coming
from Aurora database.
Now, if anyone who don't
know what Aurora is,
Aurora is our managed
relation database service.
We support my SQL, Postgres SQL,
and some other databases.
But for this demo we will
be targeting Postgres SQL
for all the structured data.
Let's move on to the next one.
So before we go in, I just want to kind of
make sure everyone knows what are
the SDKs and the agent
tools you'll be using.
So we will be building our
agent using Strand SDK.
Is there anyone who has
already done some work
with Strand in this room?
Oh, nice.
- [Aneel] Yeah, we have a couple of hands.
- [Rafia] Nice. Very nice. All right.
So Strand allow you to
build a single agent
as well as multi-agent
where the agents can talk with each other.
Strand supports MCP as
well as a two A protocol.
Here we are showing you a simple agent
where a prompt is sent to the agent.
The agent has certain tools built into it,
and based on the tool,
it'll be able to provide
the service which this
prompt is asking for, right?
So that is the model, a simple agent,
single agent, which we will
be creating today's code talk.
The next is about how do we
access unstructured data.
Now, how many of you have
written rag applications?
Okay, I see quite a few hands, right?
- [Aneel] Yeah, quite a few of them.
- [Rafia] So you guys know
the way when we bring,
when you write a RAG application,
we take our data most
likely unstructured data,
maybe in a PDF format or word format
or plain log files.
And then we convert that into vectors,
because that's what our LLM understands,
and then be able to use that,
the knowledge which is
stored in those unstructured
documents and be able to provide
AI solutions on top of it.
Now, bedrock knowledge
base allow us to build all
that rag infrastructure
very effectively and easily
and this is what we will
be showing you today,
that we will be taking some of the files,
which has some content in
let's say Word document,
and then we will be putting it
into a bedrock knowledge base
and be able to query that via our agent.
Now, because of time constraint,
we have already created a knowledge base
for our code talk,
but if any of you are
interested in knowing how
to build a knowledge base
from from scratch, please come
and talk to us after the session
and we'll be more than happy to point you
to some resources, okay?
- [Aneel] Alright, so
this is the application
that we're going to build today.
So let me play this,
let's see, alright,
so no surprise here.
We both are from the non-profit group,
so we picked the charity use case.
So we're building a charity
chat assistant, a chat bot,
that will go against structured
and unstructured data.
We have all the campaign information,
donation information in a
relational database in Aurora,
and we have some unstructured
campaign related data
in a S3 bucket, which is we are asking
through our bedrock knowledge base.
So as you can see, if
you ask some questions
that needs it to go against
the relational data source,
the AI application that we are building,
the agent application that we
are building, we'll figure out
what is the right data source to go to
and get that data automatically from
that corresponding data source.
So we are going to see all of this
and how we are going to build this.
Alright, let me switch to my ID mode.
Alright.
- [Rafia] And for most part
we will some of the UI aspect,
we'll try to take it out very fast
because there's really
nothing which is extraordinary
or something that you
guys might be interested
in learning today,
but, so the reason why we, we have this UI
so we can show you a
complete agent, right?
But as Aneel is bringing the code,
you'll see that we'll start
with the very basic structure
of the UI and then,
so yeah we'll start with showing you
a very basic UI skeleton, you know how-
- Yeah, so apologies for that.
So as you can see, I'm using
my favorite ID kiro here.
So if you're not familiar
with Kiro ID, it is
an IDE that Amazon supports
and released recently.
It's a IDE where you can do white coding
and also spec driven development.
We are not going to do any of that today.
We are just going to demonstrate
building this application,
but, and you can use
any ID for that matter.
So I'm going to start
with an empty folder here.
I already have some files here.
Let me quickly go through
what those files are doing.
I created a virtual
Python virtual environment
of three point 12
and I have a requirements file
that with all the libraries
that we are going to use today.
Talked about strands,
strands for agent and agent.
Tafia, go ahead.
- Tafia] So, if you are
working with Strand,
there are two packages,
and by the way, right now Strand
only is supporting Python.
So there are these two packages,
which you need to make sure
you bring it in your
environment to be able to use
some of the APIs and tools
we will be showing you.
One is Strand agent and the
other is Strand Agent tools.
- [Aneel] Yeah. And another
file I have is run.sh.
So we are going to build a
Streamlit app for a UI app.
So this run.sh is just
sets up my environment.
If there's no virtual
environment, it creates one
and it starts my Streamlit app at the end.
So that's all it's doing.
So just by to save some time,
we have these two files already here.
So let me start by creating a new file.
I'm going to call that app.py
and we're going to start
putting some code into it.
- [Rafia] So this app.py will have
most of our UI code in it.
- [Aneel] So as you can
imagine, you don't want me
to be typing in front
of you or all this code
and probably going through that pain of
looking at me typing.
So what we did is we are
using VS code snippets.
So to help us just bring
in code that we want.
So we are going to first just
build that shell of the UI
that we showed earlier.
So nothing fancy here, we just going to
bring in some snippets.
This first one is doing imports
and then setting up some constants.
Like if you, for those of you who probably
noticed on the left hand side,
we have some sample questions
and things like that.
So this is just bringing all those things.
Again, this file is not
the most exciting part.
Other files are, so I'm going
to just quickly go over this.
This is going to set
up my team for the app,
which is like a dark theme,
and then I'm going to
just bring in the snippet
for the chat interface.
So again, like I said,
there's nothing much here.
We just brought in a show of
a application Streamlit app.
There's one thing that I
do want you to note though.
I commented out this piece of code,
which we will un-comment
later, which we will bring in,
add in the capabilities of the agent.
For now it's just doing nothing.
So let's try to run this
and see what happens.
- [Rafia] So you'll see that right now
the UI is really not
nothing intelligent, right?
Even if you ask a question,
it might not be able
to answer it correctly.
So why don't we ask a question?
- [Aneel] Yeah, so this
is the empty application.
So let's see if we can ask a question.
I'm expecting an error to come
because we don't have any
agent capabilities yet
as expected there is a error here.
So let's move on to a little
bit more exciting part
of the session today.
Alright, if I can kill this one.
Alright, so I'm going to add another file.
I'm gonna call that agent.py.
- [Rafia] And this file
will have our core logic
of the strand agent,
which you'll see we will
be building it later on.
- Yeah, so I'm start with
just getting some import statements.
And yeah, go ahead.
- [Rafia] So as we are building
this agent, we'll walk you
through line by line, right?
The first thing, of course
we need these, we need
to import some packages,
particularly we need
to import the strand packages
and we have some other
packages like photo three
because we will be going
against Aurora database
and bedrock DB and so forth.
The next thing you'll see that
because we are going to be going against
LLM model here we are using a model ID,
which is Claude model.
So our agent will be using Claude to,
when a user gives a question, it will take
that question, it'll feed
that question into the agent.
The agent of course has to
use a LLM to be able to answer
that question, and the model
it'll use is gonna be cloud.
Now strand, SDK do allow you
to talk to any LLM, even
those LLM outside of Bedrock.
We've chosen it to be
bedrock a supported LLM.
But you, if you are doing
it, you are free to use
any other LLM.
And then the next thing we
are doing is declaring some
inference parameter, like
maximum token allowed
and temperature and so forth.
So now the first thing Aneel,
the code Aneel has put in is
that the code from line 18 to 22 is
the base model we are creating, right?
We are using a model id,
which is a cloud model id,
we've given certain parameters.
Then the code of line which,
and just put from line 28 to 29
or actually to 32, is
using the strand agent
to just create a base agent.
Now, this agent has no
intelligence in it, into it.
We just wanted to show
you two lines of code
how a agent is created.
So you'll see it's as easy
as instantiating a agent object, right?
That agent object takes
two things, it takes
a model id, which we've
already built in from line 18
to line 22, takes a model object
and then the second thing
it takes is a system prompt.
Now this, at this point,
the agent is really
just a blank canvas.
No intelligence has been built in.
- [Rafia] Yeah, notice
in the prompt we said
don't make up answers.
Just if you don't know,
say, don't know, right?
So let's run this
application again, you see?
- [Rafia] And before you
run this, I think you have
to un-comment the-
- [Aneel] Yeah, very good point.
- [Rafia] So, Aneel remember
he showed you in the app.py,
he had commented some code
because that code was what
was calling the agent.
So let's un-comment and go
through that again, right?
- [Aneel] Yeah, thank you.
- [Rafia] Let me just
explain that code Aneel.
- [Aneel] Yeah.
- [Rafia] What's your un-comment.
- [Aneel] Comment this and you go.
- [Rafia] So the code, which
Aneel un-commented, right,
that code, what it does,
it first makes sure that
the agent object is not in
the state of the Streamlit.
So Streamlit maintains,
there's a state management aspect, right?
So first is going to
check if there is already
the session state has a agent object.
If it does not, then
it'll create that agent,
the same agent which Aneel just created
in the agent.py file.
So that's what this code is doing
and we've just un-commented.
But keep in mind at this
point all it's doing,
the Streamlit is going
to be calling our agent.
Our agent has no logic.
So you would not expect
much functionality,
but when he run this code,
you might not see some intelligent answer,
but at least you won't see the
error which you saw earlier.
- [Aneel] Yeah.
So let's ask the application
the same question
we asked how many members do we have?
And let's see what it says.
So it says, I don't have access to
your organization's
current membership data.
So it's basically say, telling us that
it doesn't know the answer.
- So, at this point, we've
completed the entire structure
of our code, right?
We've built the UI, we've built a agent,
which does not have much intelligence,
but at least is functional.
And then as we move forward,
we will start building
more intelligence into it.
- [Aneel] So let's begin by adding quote
to retrieve data from the knowledge base.
- [Rafia] Yeah, so strength, remember
the architect diagram,
which I showed in the slide
after that we showed that agent
can have tools in it, right?
Strand allow you to create
your own custom tool
and it also come up with
lot of ready to use tools.
Today you'll see that we
will be using one custom tool
and one which is already available to us
from the strand SGK.
- [Aneel] Alright, so I
added the retrieve tool here.
For this retrieve tool to work
we also need to set some
environment variables.
- [Rafia] So let me, as
Aneel is typing this in,
let me tell you explain
what retrieve tool is.
Retrieve is out of the
box strand SDK tool,
which allow you to query
bedrock knowledge base.
You don't have to write any custom code
to access knowledge base,
it does it everything.
The only thing you would need, you need
to create a bedrock knowledge base, which
as I mentioned earlier,
we had already created
and the code, which Aneel
just put in on line 26,
you'll see that the knowledge
base when you create
a bedrock knowledge base,
the knowledge base gives you a unique id
and this is the unique id which
we have, which we have kind
of hardcoded here to
let retrieve tool know
which knowledge base it has to go through.
I'm gonna stop here in case
if anyone have any question on
the knowledge base.
- [Speaker 1] So one quick one,
like as I'm kind of following listening,
writing, would you mind if
time permits just give it one
more rundown after all these up?
- [Aneel] Sure, absolutely. Yeah, sure.
- [Rafia] But just to recap, okay.
When you are creating
knowledge base, you identify
your data source, where your
unstructured data is coming
from, most likely will be Word document,
PDF documents, whatever.
And then the knowledge base.
You also, when creating the
knowledge base, you also say
what is that vector database
where you'll be storing that?
All you have to identify is the
data source, a vector store,
and then the knowledge base does all
the heavy lifting for you.
Once you do go through that,
it'll give you a knowledge
base ID, which we have in,
put it in here so we can let
our strand agent know, oh,
this is a knowledge base you have to use.
- [Aneel] Yeah, I have to
put in a disclaimer here.
I know we hard coding these
IDs all over the code.
This is probably not how you would do it
if you want to take this
to production you want
to store this in some parameter store
or some other external
configuration store,
but this is just easy for
us to demonstrate this way.
- [Rafia] And as part of
these retrieve Strand agent,
it has to have, again,
the knowledge base ID
as well as the region.
Now there are two ways
you can do it, right?
You can actually give that
in two pieces of information
to retrieve tool via
environmental variable,
which we are doing it here.
So if you look at the
core on line 29 and 30,
this is where we establish
environmental variable
where the knowledge base
ID and the region where
that knowledge base is created
is injected right into the environment.
So, the retrieve tool will be able
to pick it from the environmental variable
and we'll know where to go.
Okay.
- [Aneel] Alright.
- [Speaker 1] We're
actually the knowledge base
in the vector database
is ready to be used.
- [Rafia] Exactly, exactly.
Because we had a time constraint,
we did not go through that exercise
of creating the knowledge base.
- [Speaker 2] Any standard
factors for embedding
or to create those vector
that you want us to.
- [Rafia] So yeah, go
ahead. Yeah, go, go ahead.
- [Aneel] No, with
bedrock knowledge basis,
it's a few clicks, right?
We can stay after the session and-
- [sPEAKER 2] For the specific
form of data, for example,
you the data in the Word document, right?
Any best practices, you wanna to suggest
that if a Word document
or the S format, right?
What embedding models we can use,
what the size, how we can get.
- [Rafia] So bedrock supports, yeah.
So, Bedrock supports two, embedding Model
Titan and a cohere model.
The chunking strategy, it's
a topic which is definitely
a very important topic,
but I think if you want, we
can definitely talk later on.
It would be way out of scope
for us to focus on chunking,
but it's a important thing.
Let's talk after the session.
- [Speaker 2] That is not right, right?
The answering-
- [Rafia] Absolutely, absolutely.
- [Aneel] Alright, so let's-
- [Rafia] I'm sorry, there's a question.
- [Speaker 3] Does the call to.
- [Rafia] Yes, it is.
- [Speaker 3] Can it be attached
to any other vector tool
like OpenSearch or it has to
be Bedrock knowledge base.
- [Rafia] Retrieve is for
bedrock knowledge base.
But there are, and by the
way, the strands or tools,
it's a community development tool.
So tools are coming up every day.
You might be able to find tools
which can go to other data.
- [Aneel] Alright, so, I
ran this application again.
Now let's go back and
ask the same question
we have been asking how
many members do we have?
And let's see what it does.
It's doing something now
because it's not saying, I don't know.
Alright, so it looked
in the knowledge base
and came back with some answers.
And it clearly states here, like
based on the information I
found in the knowledge base,
these is some like
number of donors we had,
but it's clearly not
coming from the structured
relational data, which
may be more accurate.
So our next step is to
extend this, to go to that.
- [Rafia] So, so now,
because what we did, we did,
we had some documents which
were related to our campaign
and it had some data in it,
but the answer was not a
hundred percent accurate.
The a hundred percent
accurate answer is sitting
in our databases, right?
Our database is where most
of our enterprise data is,
or especially when you
are already going against
your enterprise application data, right?
So now what we will be doing,
we'll be creating a custom tool.
That custom tool, what it will do,
it'll take a prompt from the user
try to answer, if this
prompt can be answered
through our relational database data.
If it can be, it's gonna convert that into
appropriate query language
and be able to retrieve that data.
So for that, the first thing
we will do is create a-
- [Aneel] Yeah, I'm adding
that custom tool, that talking.
- [Rafia] So, all Aneel did
was in the agent definition,
we already had put in a retrieve tool.
Now he also created a
query SQL DB tool, right?
We have not created this tool yet,
but that's the purpose of the tool.
So now we'll create the tool
that the entire logic of
that custom tool will be
in a separate file.
And that's what Aneel is doing.
Let's call that file query_SQL_db.py.
And this is where we will
build our custom tool.
So of course the first
thing we need to do is
import all the appropriate packages,
which we'll do first thing.
Again, strand agent and tool is one of
the fundamental packages
you need to bring in,
and that's what we have.
We also have boto3.
Boto3 is again, anybody
who have used AWS SGK,
that's a Python SGK, to access
most of our AWS services.
- [Speaker] This custom tool
you'll build using strands,
or you'll be consuming using strands.
- [Rafia] We'll build the
logic and then we will feed it
into Strand.
- [Aneel] So, this custom
tool is just a Python script.
So Strands will use this, yeah.
- [Rafia] But there are
some hooks of Strand, right?
Which we need to put
into this code so that
we can feed it into Strand.
And you'll see that the next step,
that's what we will be doing, right?
So, the first two thing
Aneel is doing right now
is actually writing that code,
and you'll see on line six to nine, right?
How do you take any code, any
custom code you've written,
and make sure that that code
can be converted into a tool
for Strand, okay?
So all you have to do to take that code
and convert as a tool for
Strand is annotate that,
create a function, put all
whatever your logic you need in
that function, and then make
that function annotated by this
tool annotation.
So, all you need is a tool annotation.
Once you have that,
and once you feed that into the strand,
strand understand that
whenever it needs to answer
a user using the tool,
it'll run this function.
Whatever is written in the
function, it's gonna run it.
So I'm gonna just make sure
everyone is clear about
how the strand plumbing
is happening, right?
It's very simple as just
one annotation, okay?
Now, what we have done,
because we don't want
to put all the logic into
this one function, right?
we are gonna be creating
a supporting class
where most our logic is going to be,
and in this particular tool function,
all we will be doing is calling
the different methods of
that supporting class.
So, let's first...
No-
- [Aneel] Yeah, I brought
in some constants and then-
- [Rafia] Okay, fine.
So, let's go back to
line the two line, right?
- [Aneel] Two, yeah, sorry, go ahead.
- [Rafia] Okay, so again, the
first thing you probably need
to do is create the-
- [Aneel] Yeah, so, I added
an MT convenience class here,
so I'm going to initialize that.
- [Rafia] Yeah, so this
is the DB structure
data agent class.
It's nothing but a
supporting, which will have
most of our data, most of our logic.
Now, the structure of this class
takes four pieces of argument.
The first is the ARN of
where our Aurora database is.
For those folks who might
not have worked with Aurora,
when you create a database in Aurora,
it gives you a unique ARN
through which you can
identify the database.
So that's all we are doing
and as Aneel has already
mentioned, this is not
a true production ready code.
So we are kind of hard coding things here,
but what Aneel did,
Aneel, can you scroll up?
He defined few constants
and you'll see that
in this four constants we've defined
where our database is coming from.
So we've defined the ARN of Aurora.
Line eight is ARN for the secrets manager.
So as a best practice, right?
Whenever you are accessing a database,
of course you need the
credentials for that database.
As a best practice, you
should never hard code
those credentials in the
code or even in config files,
especially if you are publishing that code
into some sort of a repository, right?
So Secrets Manager is
one of the AWS services,
which makes the storage
of credentials very easy
and convenient.
And that's what we've done.
We've stored our database
credentials and Secret Manager,
but here we are just bringing the ARN of
that Secrets Manager.
Then the other constance, which
Aneel declared was the name
of our database, which is
called NPCO membership.
Here, you'll notice that we
also have identified LLM,
which is not a CLO model,
which we had used earlier,
but we are using a different NOVA model.
Now, first of all, why we are doing this,
I want to take a minute to explain that.
Our agent itself, so agent
is communicating with LLM
and the tool within the agent is also
communicating with LLM.
For the agent communication,
we are using Claude,
for the tool, which will
be part of the agent
we using Nova.
The reason we did that is
because we wanted to make sure
you guys understand that
you can use multiple models
for different things, right?
The model evaluation is a big component
when you are creating AI applications.
So just so that we can give that demo,
we've purposely are using
a different model here.
- [Aneel] By the way, is
this legible to everybody,
like in the back or do you
want me to increase the font?
Yes, thank you. I should have done that.
- [Rafia] Thank you. I could also not it,
- [Speaker 5] But is the
tool not just per rack,
because you already have that clock aging,
this tool is just patient now from Aurora
and feeding back to that
agent cloud aging, right?
- [Rafia] So a agent has a rack component
and another component
which is going against
structured data.
Rack is going against unstructured data.
- [Speaker 5] Oh, the previous tool?
- [Rafia] Yeah, yeah.
The retrieve tool was going
against unstructured data,
this custom, so now you
have two branches of data.
- [Aneel] And you'll see
why we need another model,
or we could have used the same model,
but why we need an LLM
model at all for this tool.
You'll see.
- [Speaker 5] The last
one, you'll keep both
or you'll just switch one to up.
- [Rafia] No.
So we will make sure
the LLM is smart enough
to decide should I be
going against the rack tool
or should I be going against
the structured database tool?
That would be the cloud model.
Okay, so now everyone is clear, right?
So far what we've done? Yeah, please.
- [Speaker] We're using
just basically to figure out
what your structure data
is and create a query.
- [Rafia] Absolutely.
Exactly. You nailed it. Okay.
There are two things, right?
One is we need to make sure
that LLM understand our database.
We want to make sure that if
it's could answer any question,
then and you'll see as
we move forward, right?
But everyone is so far clear
on the way we've defined
the plumbing for strength
tool and the creation of
the helper class.
Now, as we will start building
function in this helper class
to do different things.
The first function we will build, okay?
It is so that our LLM can
understand the database schema.
Without understanding the database schema.
it cannot answer, right?
So the first, what are
we calling this function?
- [Aneel] I think I
pulled the wrong function.
Sorry. Yeah, go ahead.
Generate schema.
- [Rafia] Okay. Yep.
So now every relational
database okay, has a capability
via some system tables
or that you can actually
use that capability
to query what, how your
database looks like,
what are the tables, what are
the columns of those tables,
what are the data types of the columns
and so forth, right?
So the first function,
which we are showing
it's called get table schema,
and you'll see that this is
nothing complicated, okay?
All it is going to be doing
and can you show that query?
Please go.
- [Aneel] Yeah. So I need
to pull in the query too.
- [Rafia] So this is a query,
and again, we are defining
it as a variable here.
In order for us to go to Postgres SQL
and be able to pull
what's in the PostgreSQL,
this is a query, okay?
If you are using, let's say Oracle
or if you're using Microsoft SQL Server,
every database has a mechanism
and that you probably just have to change
this query syntax for whatever
database you would be using.
But the rest would be same, right?
So the first function we
put together was get table schema.
Did we already add that in the two?
- [Aneel] No, let me add that.
I'm going to add that thing.
- [Rafia] Yeah, so we
created our helper class.
Then the second thing we will do,
we will actually query the
SQL or query our database.
In our case is Aurora Postgres SQL.
We are querying it and saying
give me the entire schema
in adjacent format.
And that is now being stored
in the DB_schema variable,
which is on line 82.
I'm gonna pause here, make
sure everyone is clear on it.
No question. Oh, you have a question?
- [Speaker] So is schema
low enough for some sample?
- [Rafia] So right now
you'll see schema is enough,
but yeah, sample data might,
I don't know, depending on
what you're trying to do
it, you might think that
maybe providing a sample data in a prompt
might make it more effective.
- [Aneel] Yeah, you'll see
how we wrote the prompt so
that without the sample
it'll still get it.
- [Rafia] Okay, so once we
know the database schema,
I'm sorry, I have a question.
- [Speaker] One question.
Let's say you record the schema with this,
but you wanna add some
more information to schema
because part name is
probably not very intuitive
for the is that something
- [Rafia] Yeah,
so very good question, right?
Maybe you can then inject some sort
of a transformation logic
before you send that schema to LLM, right?
That's one way of doing it.
Another way of doing it might be that
that transformation logic you can embed
in the system prompt, which
you'll be sending to the LLM.
Whenever you send anything to LLM,
you do provide some context,
some prompt, right? Yeah.
- [Speaker] Just adding to
that question, if for example,
my schema has foreign keys and stuff
and sometimes the LM needs to do like two
or three queries to help it,
there you have only the table
schema with the columns.
Is it possible to put in the schema,
the relationship as well?
- [Rafia] You absolutely.
So right now we chose our
schema, which is very simple.
But if there was relationship,
which we need to make sure,
because let's say right
now when the queries
which will be answered
from will be most likely
from one table.
If that is the case, then
we will make sure that
the prompt which we are
providing has that relationship.
So the SQL generation has the joins in it.
- [Speaker] Yeah. Got it.
- [Rafia] Right, at the end of the day,
when you are creating a
database, you are only
going against sending a SQL statement.
Your SQL statement has to have
that relationship built into.
Right. All right.
So now once the second
thing we will show you is
that system prompt generation, right?
See, remember that system prompt gives
that intelligence, okay?
In your case, you could have
added like the system pro
that hey, this
transformation should happen.
You could have added that
relationship information.
Let's see what we are producing
in the system problem.
- [Aneel] Yeah. So it-
- [Rafia] So I'll go a
little bit line by line.
Can you move up a little bit?
Alright, so this is the system
problem we are creating.
We are saying, the first
thing we are saying,
you are in AI assistance
that create system prompt
for database query.
At this point we are asking LLM
to create a prompt,
which itself has the database
schema embedded into it.
So we are gonna take that
prompt, we are going to embed
with the user question and
send the whole thing together.
I'm gonna make sure everyone got it right.
- [Speaker] One more time.
- [Rafia] Sure.
Let's say you have a user question, right?
User question now send needs
to be sent to Claude model
to answer.
In order for us to send that user question
to the Cloud, we need to build a context
which we will be building
through the prompt.
Everyone clear so far, right?
That context, which we will be building,
needs to have that database
information into it, right?
So instead of us hard coding that context,
what we are telling Nova model, use that,
use the schema, which
you got, give a prompt,
which then I'm gonna subsequently
send to cloud model so
that it can tie the database
schema with the user question.
- [Aneel] Let me see.
We will be here after,
so if you wanna just
go over the code again.
- But so here we are
saying to in the prompt,
Hey, look, you, your job
is to create a smart prom
with this database
knowledge embedded in it.
We are giving it the
schema_Jason on line 96,
which holds our schema
information in a variable.
And we've built this whole thing
and now we are gonna be
sending it to the LLM
and at this point, all
the LLM did was gave us
a smart prompt, which we
will then be able to send it
to cloud model.
- [Speaker] And where the user
prompt is coming into this.
- [Aneel] Yeah, yeah. We'll see that.
- [Rafia] We will see that.
Okay, so now we got our,
the first line was our getting our schema.
The second line was make creation of
that system prompt.
And in this system prompt,
we provided the db_schema
to this function.
So at this point, the line 137,
now we have a prompt which has
our schema embedded into it.
Yeah.
- [Speaker] Any specific
reason why we are passing
this information to other agent,
like this agent should
intelligent enough to answer
and it has the context of the question
and as well as the-
- [Rafia] We are building just
a tool for the agent, right?
What the agent will do, the agent takes
the user input sends it to this tool.
Now this tool, along with
the schema it has, is going
to come up with a SQL query
if it can be answered, right?
Alright, so the third is now
we got our database schema,
we got a prompt.
Now the thing is we need to
tie these two thing together.
We have to now ask a LLM
to generate a SQL query if
that SQL query can be,
if the user question can be
answered through a SQL query.
So let me rephrase this, right?
Let's say my prompt was,
and by the way, our database is related
to a membership model, right?
It has a table like membership, events
campaigns, donors, those
kind of things, right?
But what if I ask a question,
what is the capital of France?
Now that question cannot be answered
from a SQL query from my database.
So when I send my schema
and my user, the LLM will say, well
these two things don't
match, so it cannot come up
with a valid SQL query.
So the third function is,
it's actually is now
taking the user input,
knowing the database schema
is gonna go to the Nova model
and say, can you provide
a valid SQL statement,
which can answer this
particular user question.
- [Speaker] In your previous
statement, you said that
you go back to the cloud model
and then it comes back again.
Now what I understand that
once you see the system from,
there's no need to go back
back to the cloud model,
you can directly go back to the nova,
you get an P to execute,
- [Rafia] But the cloud model is.
- [Speaker] That's the first step.
- [Rafia] The cloud model
will go not only fit the
database, it also could
go against the rag.
- [Speaker] Exactly.
After the schema
generation, there's no need
to go back to the cloud model, right?
- [Aneel] Yeah.
The Nova model is doing.
- [Rafia] Exactly, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Speaker] You marry this
schema with the cloud good
to the cloud, no, you go to
the know get the SP execute.
- [Rafia] Yeah.
So the cloud model will only be utilized
to say if I need to go to the database.
- [Speaker] Yeah, but once
it gets the context of
the schema, then the second
call, then I be fit for.
- [Rafia] Yeah, because here you'll see
if I can generate a valid
SQL for the user prompt,
it's going to not only
give me a SQL, it's going
to actually give me the
data of that, you know?
- [Aneel] Simplest way to
think of it is this tool could
have been static, right?
Like you just, if this is the
query, this is the SQL query.
If this is the user query,
this is the SQL query,
we are putting intelligence into this tool
that we are building using
the LLM model to generate
that query dynamically for us.
Quick time check. We have 14 minutes,
so we'll move a little bit faster.
- [Rafia] Okay. So now
we got our system prompt.
The third thing we what Aneel
is typing in is actually
getting those two plumping
things together, right?
The database schema and the user prompt.
So the third thing we will
have is a helper function
called generate SQL.
Let's type this in and let's
go to the definition of
generate SQL please.
- [Aneel] Yeah.
- [Rafia] So again, in
our supporting class,
we have a generate SQL.
Let's go a little bit and make sure
we understand this right.
- [Aneel] Oh, where did
I put it? Where is it?
Alright, yeah.
- [Rafia] So if you look at
this, yeah generate SQL, okay.
What it did was it took the user prompt,
which is in the question variable,
and at this point it
has the a system prompt,
which has the database schema into it.
It defines the model,
which is our Nova model.
And then it asks LLM, Hey look, LLM,
this is my schema, this is my user.
If you think can a valid SQL
can be generated out of it,
give me that Gen SQL.
So once this function is executed,
you will have the valid SQL.
But now what we are also
doing it, we, we want
to make sure the valid SQL is
in some sort of a delimiters
so we can extract them very
well conveniently, right?
So you need to-
- [Aneel] And the ERs, yeah.
- [Rafia] Okay, so in our
going to no models, right?
When we are saying can
you create a valid SQL?
We are also going to say if
you can create a valid SQL,
make sure the valid SQL is
in this SQL start delimiter
and SQL delimeter, okay?
Once our valid SQL is in there, so when
the next function, which is going to pull
that SQL out knows exactly from the output
which I got from the model where I have
to pull the SQL out from.
Everybody okay till for this. Okay.
Alright, so you know the line 226, right?
Is where by this time if
everything is working fine I would
have a valid SQL.
Then line 227 is another function which is
extracting that SQL.
All it is going to do is going
to take the output from LLM,
make sure between those two
start and end dilimeters,
I can pull the valid SQL out.
And nothing complicated here.
Yes please.
- [Speaker] I see your-
- [Rafia] I'm sorry, I can you,
- [Speaker] You're information on schema.
I see that. Don't you
need a data dictionary?
What if the column names are,
let's say city is spelled
CTY, something like that.
How do you know what's in that column?
- [Rafia] Yeah, so it's
a very good question
and I'll, you know what I'll give you,
maybe we can run an example of that.
Our model in our database,
a table is called campaign.
What we will do, instead
of using the word campaign,
we will use the word event
for instance in a prompt.
And that's a beauty of some of this
doing it through LLM.
The LLM is smart enough to understand
that there's a semantic meaning
between event and campaign.
So even though the database
itself has a word campaign
in the table it associated
with the word event
and be able to get the
generic SQL correctly.
- [Speaker] That is a no
- [Rafia] Yeah, that's
a no, but that's a no,
but that is part that could
be part of any LLMs, right?
- [Speaker] Okay. So this
question is completely different.
For example, I give you a
schema that has column A
less column one, column two, column three.
And so by seeing this
column one, column two,
column three, nobody knows what it's
there is also information
about this column.
So, if I pass the information schema,
other column two, color three is Chinese.
- [Rafia] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Speaker] Right, right.
We can't understand.
- [Aneel] So if the column
names are so cryptic like
that exactly, you can pass
the data dictionary also
into your prompt and then
it'll know like how to-
- [Rafia] Not another tool.
You don't want to have so
many tools you might want
to make this tool smart
enough that along with
maybe along with your database information
where you are pulling
the SQL you can have it.
Oh, by the way, we did
not talk about memory.
- [Aneel] Yeah, so in
reality, if you're doing this
in production for example,
you don't want to keep going
to the database and
generating this system prompt
over and over again because
the schema is fixed, right?
Maybe it changes once a month
or only when you want to do
that update when the schema changes.
So you can use memory
tools like for example,
if you're deploying this
using a Amazon agent core
where you run your AI agents, there is a
feature functionality that comes
with agent code that's called memory.
So it can keep track
of this kind of caching
that you want to do with the-
- [Rafia] See and your data
dictionaries could also be
part of that memory, you know?
Exactly, you don't keep on change
you don't change your schemas in your data
dictionary so often, right?
So make it again, for this particular,
we've already said it
is not a hundred percent
production ready because
we wanted to make it so
that it's easy for everyone
to understand what's happening.
- [Aneel] So I added also
a function to execute
that same SQL that we just got,
and I'm going to run this again.
- So after we extracted our SQL,
we wrote another function
called execute SQL.
Again, no brainer there, right?
It's just gonna take out
SQL it knows how to query
a Postgres SQL is gonna feed
that SQL into Postgres SQL.
If you are going against
any other database, Oracle
or any other, you probably
will use whatever mechanism
of querying that database you are using.
As long as you have a valid
SQL, that's all you need
to talk to a relational database,
- [Aneel] So I'm asking the same question.
Theoretically now it should
be going to the database
to get the exact number
of members that we have.
Let's see if we can do that
or if I missed some step
somewhere it happens.
Well looks like-
- [Rafia] So you see now the
5,000 member is not coming
from rag.
An maybe we should tell
them where it's coming from.
- [Aneel] Yeah. So this is
coming from the database.
I mean if you see there's a toggle here
that will actually show
you how the query is going.
- [Rafia] So maybe let's
run it to show the audience,
because you'll be able
to see whether it send it
to the SQL tool order or the rack tool.
So now when the question was asked, what
- I asked answer question,
what membership levels exist?
So again, this is in the database,
we have three membership levels.
So you can see that when
you expand this tool usage,
it'll show you what it does,
it went to the database,
it got these results.
But if I'm asking question
like did we run an event
to support elderly?
This probably will go against
the knowledge base instead
of going against the database.
- [Rafia] Because this
information is not in a database.
- [Speaker] This decision
Claude is making,
- [Rafia] Claude is making, exactly.
Once Claude make the decision
which tool it's going to use,
if database tool database needs to be used
for the answer, then Nova
will come into picture.
- [Aneel] One thing I
do want to highlight is
in our app.py,
our system prompt is, sorry,
in our agent.py, our system
prompt is still basic,
but our tool, our
application is simple enough
that the LLM is able to
figure out that it needs to go
to the database or structure data.
But it is always a best practice
to give good system prompt
to make sure your LLM behaves in more
or less the way that you want
to behave rather than
just leaving it up to it.
So we could have replaced
this system prompt
with something more robust like
So right now you'll see
when Aneel is going to put
a very prompt smart system prong
because our code example was so simple
that Claude was able to find this out.
But imagine if you had
multiple knowledge bases,
multiple databases, you were
even doing transformation,
you were defining data dictionary.
When you are making that
complicated type of agent
where it's excelling multiple structured,
non-structured data sources.
Your system prompt becomes
very, very important.
The more information you
provide in that system prom,
the more intelligent
Claude would be to give,
to decide which tool is going to use.
- [Aneel] You're kind of
defining your agent's personality
with this system prompt.
So I mean it is very important to have
that good system prompt.
Alright, so I want to wrap this up.
We have only two minutes.
As you can see, we just
build a demo application.
It's not production
ready, but if you want,
if you have built this
application, if you want
to deploy this in AWS you
have multiple choices.
You have choices like you
can run this in AWS Lambda
container services like ECS
or EKS or use our latest
and greatest runtime for running
these agent tech applications agent code.
It's because it's just Python, right?
So it can't run it in any compute.
We are not deploying this into anywhere.
We just running it off of any EC2 machine
that's sitting in AWS
but theoretically you can
pick any of these choices
to go there.
And finally, if you want to
learn more about Agentic Ai,
there are some resources here
and please don't forget
to submit survey for-
- [Speaker] No look.
- [Aneel] Yeah, exactly.
- [Speaker] Yeah.
- [Rafia] And we will be
here after the session,
so please feel free to stay.
I don't know if you can stay in this room,
but We'll we can definitely go outside
and then we'll be happy
to answer any question.
I know, sir, you wanted to give
us like a one more rundown.
- [Speaker] I even have a
smaller question, you know?
- [Aneel] Okay.
- [Rafia] Yeah.
- [Aneel] So yeah, we'll stay
here. We can chat we'll, yeah.
- [Rafia] Absolutely.
And we can also talk about, I'm sorry,
we can talk about your question. Okay.
- [Aneel] Alright. So yeah, sorry. Yeah.
- [Rafia] I'm sorry I didn't get.
- [Speaker] Knowledge base.
- [Rafia] So you want
to know how to create
a knowledge base?
Of course. Yeah, we can share that.
- [Aneel] Yeah, we can do that too. Yeah.
- [Speaker] Share the code.
- [Aneel] Share the code.
All right, we will get it up
on GitHub and maybe share it.
If you can connect with
one of us on LinkedIn,
we'll make that.
- [Rafia] Yeah, actually
we were going to do share
the code even before the session
but didn't go to our review yet.
- [Aneel] If you go to the
app, you pick the session
and you submit this.
- [Rafia] So thank you all
for coming and we will be-
- [Aneel] Yeah, thank you very much.